MARCHAND OUT HIGH.
AND THEY'VE GOT ACYK.
AND THEY CAN'T GET A PASS AS HE
>> OFF THEE
NET.
BUT I'LL TELL YOU WHAT, THAT'S
AND HE SHOOTS.
AND WEDGEWOOD TRIES TO COVER UP
YOU WANT TO
>> HE HAD A GOAL THE OTHER NIGH
INONSTER OF A GOAL.
AND A LUCKY BOUNCE O WE MENTION
FIFTH LATE IN THATAK.
AND THIS WILL BE AN ICING NIGHT
>> CHARLIE COYLE, OUT OF THE CO
PLAY. ER MOVE FAIEHIND THE NE.
THE SHOT, AND IT'S UNDERNEATH.
THAT IS IN THE CALENDAR
MONTH FOR DOWN, THEY GET YOU
CHASING. GOSTISBEH. LADD HAS GO
PHIL THEPLAYERS FROM THE 2006 D
CLASS.
>> WELL, YOU CERTAINLY HAVE THE
NASH COMES
SAVE!
MAYBE THE SAVE OF THE NIGHT.
>> THEY'RE UPMENTIONED.
OF THEIR GAMEPPED BY THE DOING
THING.
HE WANTED TO GET HIS WILL BRING
THE STICK IN